Conditional probabilities are
like ordinary probabilities,
except that they apply to a
new situation where some
additional information
is available.
For this reason, any concept
relevant to probability models
has a counterpart
that applies to
conditional probability models.
In this spirit, we can define
a notion of conditional
independence, which is nothing
but the notion of independence
applied to a conditional
model.
Let us be more specific.
Suppose that we have a
probability model and two
events, A and B. We are then
told that event C occurred,
and we construct a conditional
model.
Conditional independence
is defined as ordinary
independence but with respect
to the conditional
probabilities.
To be more precise, remember
that independence is defined
in terms of this relation, that
the probability of two
events happening is the product
of the probabilities
that one of them is happening
times the probability that the
other one is happening.
This is the definition of
independence in the original
unconditional model.
Now, in the conditional model we
just use the same relation,
but with conditional
probabilities instead of
ordinary probabilities.
So this is the definition of
conditional independence.
We may now ask, is there a
relation between independence
and conditional independence?
Does one imply the other?
Let us look at an example.
Suppose that we have two events
and these two events
are independent.
We then condition on another
event, C. And suppose that the
picture is like the
one shown here.
Are A and B conditionally
independent?
Well, in the new universe where
C has happened, events A
and B have no intersection.
As we discussed earlier this
means that events A and B are
extremely dependent.
Within G, if A occurs, this
tells us that B did not occur.
The conclusion from this example
is that independence
does not imply conditional
independence.
So in this particular example,
we saw that the
answer here is no.
Given C, A and B are
not independent.